foreign
might be seated ladies and gentlemen
we're ready to proceed with the defense
case
sorry for the slight delay we did have
to address some legal issues which have
been taken care of we're now moving on
to the defense case mr blinkness call
your first witness please joseph
blattner
joseph blatler to the stand please
please remain standing place your left
hand on the bible
do you stir in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes i do please state your
name as well your last name for the
record joseph j blatler b-l-a-e-t-t
l-e-r thank you all right you may have a
seat sir
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone does not um it only
records
it doesn't project your voice in the
courtroom at all so you have to keep
your voice up if you don't understand
the question please indicate that and
i'll have council rephrase the question
yes all right and if you hear an
objection stop answering
until the court rules on the objection
all right very good sir mr blankens go
ahead thank you
mr blakely where do you live
i live in morristown
what do you do for an occupation i'm a
private investigator
do you have a
company name yes east coast private
investigations in new jersey and can you
give us a little bit of your background
please
my background i'm a retired deputy chief
of police from the city of union city i
was there for 23 years after retiring i
became a private investigative slash
police consultant
and who have you consulted for
numerous law firms county of suffolk
georgetown law center
and the name of your company is what's
there east coast private investigations
of new jersey
do you know my client michael barrison
just by name
and uh uh were you contacted at any
point in a professional capacity by
michael barrasso yes
and and when was that honor about july
31st of 2019.
and um
did he hire you to do something
yes what did he hire you to do he asked
me to contact two background checks for
him
and can you tell me the names of the two
people he had to do background checks i
believe one was goodwin and the other
one was i don't know how to pronounce
the names of the k.a
cataract cataract
all right and and did you do a
background check on both of those
individuals yes i did
and did you provide your background
check to mr barrison after you completed
it yes i did
i'm going to show you what's been marked
defense exhibit 700 a1
and asked you
if you recognize this document
these are the background checks i
conducted however this one document i
don't recognize
we will then just take that out of there
sorry
and after you
conducted
your business
did you provide michael barrasson with a
copy of 700 a1
yes i did
did you have any other discussions with
michael barrasson
i did have other discussions with them
but i really don't recall what they were
all right
judge i move in 781
i object
the objection is sustained
go ahead mr balance with regards to the
background check-in and i do not want
you to say anything specific
what does that background check look at
looks at people's previous residents
relatives phone numbers
liens judgments bankruptcies criminal
histories
it's
employment comes up sometimes
any close examination briefly judge mr
blatler you never met uh robert goodwin
no and you never met lauren canara no
and you didn't uh
confirm or corroborate any of the
information that showed up in the
background check no
did you and you told mr barristone
certain methods that he could do to
verify these things if you wanted to yes
if you wish to follow up thank you sir
no further questions all right you may
step down sir
i'm sorry mr blink is any redirect
you may step down thank you sir
thank you
defense calls larry davison
mr davidson
hi mr davidson please remain standing
for a moment if you would please place
your left hand on that bible
raise your right hand listen to my court
clerk please
do you sway in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes i do please state your
name as for your last name for the
record lawrence davidson
d-a-v-i-d-s-o-n
thank you
all right you may have a seat sir please
keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it it does
not project your voice in the courtroom
all right so you have to keep your voice
up if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase if you hear any counsel object
uh please stop answering until the court
resolves that objection go ahead mr
blancas thank you
mr davidson uh
where do you live
uh glenn gardner new jersey
and and can you tell the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury what you do for a
living
i drive a truck
and and who do you work for specifically
uh robert jenkins the nursery
and and what do you specifically do for
them just drive call trees okay
uh do you know my client michael
barrison yes i do
how long have you known him i see a
smile on your face how long have you
known him uh probably 20 years anyway
okay and how do you know him
i've known from
the farm
you know
i've you know worked for him
brought hay in for him and stuff like
that
okay
did there come a time
uh in august of 2019
where michael barrasson
hired you to do something other than all
hay or
deliver things from the nursery yes
what did he hire you to do he asked me
to uh watch what's the barn
and when you say
watch the barn yeah what were you
watching for
uh
uh
well he was having problems with the
girl that was in the house
and i don't even know her name or
anything
did he express concerns about her yes
and is that specifically why
he asked you to uh to come there yes
and what time would you come
um during the day
probably like eight o'clock at night
i wouldn't be there during the day just
nighttime okay and uh
what time did you leave
uh like six o'clock in the morning
i i had coffee with mike and
trying to talk to him but he was so
he was so
i don't know just so messed up that he
could even hardly talk
all right so
uh do you recall the first time
you came to the property uh
um
on a particular night
oh the first time first time yeah
i was uh driving up there
and the
girl comes out of the house comes
running out of the house and says who
are you who are you who are you i just
kept on going
and i got up to the
farm and i saw mike
and uh
and then
sat there for maybe ten ten minutes
and two cars come up the driveway
and as an old boy
at some point
um did those people in those two cars
identify themselves
well
yeah one one around the barn
and one pulled up by me
and and they were pleased so they were
unmarked cars i know where they were
and
did you have a discussion with the
police
just all he said was uh
how's everything i said it was quiet
right now
and and that was it
and he left did they ask you what you
were doing there or why you were hired
by michael barrison no nothing
now so um
i'm not sure
if you told us the first day that you
came here where this incident happened
was that august 1st
i believe so yes
okay and uh did you come there each
night thereafter
to the day of the incident yes
and uh
each night
what would you do what was your life job
just to park
by the barn make sure nobody goes in a
bar
okay
and and during that week leading up to
the shooting did you have occasion to
see
michael barrisson i seen mike every
night yep
he he constantly was walking the
property
constantly walking the property
after hours
yeah all night
all night he was walking the property
and did you have an opportunity to
observe him physically
like his
his physical appearance
yes it was he wasn't i don't know he was
just terrible he just he just couldn't
he was beside himself
and you've known him for how long
20 years have you ever seen him anywhere
near in this condition during that
20-year period never and
with regards to your observation
what specifically
did you observe about his physical
appearance
he was just
just distraught he was uh
i mean he could hardly talk he could
hardly talk
he used to have coffee in the morning
he'd be he'd be sitting at the desk
there and
i'm trying to talk to him and
he was just
he was out of he was out of it
now you said you you observed him
walking the property
every night every night i was there
what hours of the night
well i got there like eight or nine
o'clock
and he was he was up all night all night
see he come out and see me and then he
go back
you know back around again and be on the
porch and then come back out again
and how many times would he do this
on each night
probably three or four times a night
come out you know by me
did you notice anything in the way he
was dressing that was different than you
uh you previously observed prior to
these uh
mr shellhorn any cross-examination just
briefly go ahead mr davis good afternoon
do you remember uh being interviewed by
members of the prosecutor's office on
october 2nd 2020
uh
where was that at
did they did they meet you at the
hundred and county hospital center yeah
do you remember that interview yes you
probably talked to them for about an
hour that day yeah
um and you didn't mention anything to
them during the course of that interview
about anyone running out of the house or
trying to flag you down
i don't know maybe i did i don't know
we didn't talk about that
you would agree with me that uh during
the time that you were there at the farm
on the overnights no one ever tried to
come and enter the barn during the times
you were there no
no no
what guy came up and
you know surprised me was mike
he come he can walk it up by the truck
oh okay like
nothing further thank you all right any
redirect no jim all right you may step
down sir thank you mr davidson thank you
[Music]
gibbs right miss uh christiana
gibbs cook gibbs
hi ma'am just remain standing for a
moment if you place your left hand on
the bible on the witness stand
please raise your right hand and listen
to my question
do you swear in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth i do please state your name by
your last name for the record christiana
cook gibbs
c-o-o-k-e hyphen gi bbs thank you all
right miss cook gibbs you may have a
seat please keep your voice up nice and
loud
like that microphone does not project
your voice it just records so you have
to speak loudly if you don't understand
the question please indicate that
go ahead mr malinkas thank you
ms
where are you with
i live in alamouchi new jersey and uh
who are you employed by i'm employed by
the township of washington and morris
county
and
can you briefly describe your
your background
um i have a
bachelor's of science degree in animal
science i have my master's in public
health
okay who do you currently work for
washington township morris county
and what uh what's your specific
position for that my specific title is
that i am the health officer for the
health department of washington township
and how long have you been doing that
i've been employed by washington
township for 36
years and and what does that entail like
what's your
job description
um
being a rural
uh community the bulk of my position it
was um i i'm charged with administrating
administering laws that protect public
health
both municipal and state
a lot of my job involves environmental
work septics and wells we do
everything from rabies to food
inspections last two years covet
okay
did you have an occasion to respond to
my client michael barrison's property on
august 6th
i
did and before we get to that
um
prior to that day
um did you know michael barrasso i did
and how did you know him uh through
dealings with the property um
the property was a farm
and
at some point
in the late 1990s it was developed into
a dressage facility and a large
equestrian center was built
and i was involved with the permitting
of both the front home that was moved
and made into a double home
and then the equestrian center in the
back so well and septic permits i was
involved with
from the beginning of the development of
the property and
then somewhere
michael wasn't my primary contact with
the property
but eventually
michael turned out to be my point person
there and i remember there was a septic
problem
in about 10 years in and we had to rep
rebuild the septic and at that point
michael was was the point person for the
property
okay so prior to the six
over the years you've had an opportunity
to
come in contact with michael and observe
him
um
in normal day affairs correct yes sir
and how would you describe him
in those days
um very confident
very dignified elegant man
you know
on the sixth
uh do you know uh who signed the
complaint against the
michael barrasson that caused you to go
to the property well how have we
established that
i want to ask some
foundational questions
why did you go to the property
i went to the property because a
complaint
was
received by another department in in the
township
the bill the construction department
received a complaint
alleging
that unpermitted work had happened at
the property
um
and
ancillary to that it would have involved
my department there was allegations that
an apartment was constructed
in the barn
and and therefore
it would have impacted my authority and
how does that impact your authority uh
your apartment in the board
because the septic system for the barn
was only sized to accommodate a certain
amount of flow septics are designed for
gallons and that septic was only
designed
for
a very specific purpose and not to
accommodate living space
okay and uh
prior to going to the property
did you ascertain who made the complaint
i
i don't recall i
the complaint was not made directly to
me i did not have any interaction with
the complaint before i went on the
property okay
now when you said you went on the
property
did
anyone else go with you
i specifically drove to the property
with my colleague from the health
department but we met there at the same
time with representatives of the
construction department and the fire
official
so we all can kind of convened on the
property at the same time in different
vehicles
there could have there would have been
at least three vehicles maybe four but
at least three
okay and
at some point in time
um did you have an opportunity
to observe michael barrasso yes i did
and
did you observe him before
you and the other town officials started
doing your job so to speak walking
around and looking at things
we originally um arrived to the property
and and got out of the cars at the house
in the front the two family house
took a look around
didn't appear that anyone was there we
knocked on the doors
no one was there so we were getting in
the cars to go back the barn is quite a
distance off the road and then
the
gentleman who i found out who was the
complaint and arrived
spoke to
a con the construction official i i
backed away from the conversation i
wasn't part of it
and again when you say the person that
made the complaint who was that
i
i believe his name was robert but i
don't i don't particularly remember his
last name
yes now you indicated that uh
when robert goodwin started talking to
the construction officials you backed
away i did why did you do that i just
didn't didn't get a good feeling about
you know he didn't complain to me he
didn't reach out to me and i just
just i i literally backed away
did there come a time when you uh uh
went up towards the stable area the barn
area yes we did we we all got in our
cars and we proceeded
up to the stable
and at that point
did you have an opportunity to see
michael barrasso i did
he and um mr lundberg who was the
gentleman who i had originally dealt
with on the property from the beginning
were outside
sitting on the porch i recall and
we
mr lumber got up and came and greeted me
and i then walked back
with mr lundberg and we spoke with
michael at the time to let him know why
we were there okay
and
you mentioned the name lundberg and
someone that you were dealt with is he
michael's a partner in that stable as
far as you know
i don't know what the official
relationship was between mr barizone and
mr lundberg but i assume it was a
a business
arrangement and a you know
a mutual passion for what they were
doing there
now
do you recall when you first observed
michael barisson on that day i do
and can you tell the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury what your uh
impressions were when you first saw him
he was very distraught
very disheveled
very very upset
can you describe his physical appearance
um unlike my prior meetings with him he
was
he he was very very very different he
was
you know sweating and
pacing
and mumbling
did he appear to have bathed recently
i don't remember
i i couldn't get that specific but it
was
much much different than any prior
meeting that i had had with him
would shocking be a reasonable term
it was very subjection
that's a little leaning mr balinkas
sustained
how would you describe
your observations
previously
with the observations on
august 6th
a very different person
in what way
um he was
he was disheveled he was
upset he he was
undone
he
um
he wasn't the competent
guy that i remember and um very very uh
he made
comments about
being fearful
uh
objection judge
it's not yes
anything else that
pops into your mind regarding your
observations of him
um no what was your your impression of
him
based on your observations
he was very very distraught and
and
very very different
nothing further
close examination
cook gibbs had you ever met the
individual that you referred to as
robert goodwin
before that day i had not
and did you
feel like after meeting him that he
didn't fit there
objection
what's the basis for the objection
the impression of whether he fit there i
don't even know
yeah i mean
you had her
describe what she did when she met him
and that's seems to be
follow-up by the state
overall
do you recall when you were interviewed
by members of the washington township
police department on september 17th of
2019.
i i honestly didn't didn't remember it
until i got subpoenaed um
but
now i do remember being
interviewed um it was a long time ago um
do you recall telling them that you you
felt like mr goodwin didn't fit there i
did
i do
you showed or you and the other township
officials came to the property on august
6th unannounced
we did i i mean i don't know if the
construction department
announced i i went there unannounced i
can speak for myself only
meaning the health department did not
notify anyone that they were coming
that's correct
did you ever observe uh mr mr barissone
during a training session
actually
yes um
i was on the property once
to um
watch a horse
and i i believe mr barrison was there
what was his demeanor during the course
of that training session very
professional
now
you responded on august 6 to investigate
potential
health issues or environmental issues
that's correct and did you identify
health issues and environmental issues
i
observed um
i
i observed uh work that was done without
permits that would have required
um the health department involvement i
didn't um
an environmental issue like an end
result of of it no
but
you know i didn't i didn't observe a
malfunctioning septic or something like
that but i did observe work that should
have been permitted and and should have
been reviewed and authorized before it
was done
for example that the septic system would
have been overloaded by the number of
bathrooms or something like that right
which could have could have led to a
problem down the road if it wasn't
located and identified by you on august
6th
uh
yes no further questions judge
just one more
go ahead can you explain
why you didn't feel like robert goodwin
didn't fit in there
when you never really met him before
i just got a bad feeling i just
i don't know what
nothing further all right you may step
down man thank you very much
all right mr blinkers call your next
witness
bill her wagon
mr bill her wagon
hello sir hello
please remain standing place your left
hand on that bible and just turn this
way face my lawn clerk she'll administer
my court clerk excuse me
do you saw the presence of almighty god
the testimony good to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
yes i do please state your name as well
your last name for the record william
herrera jr h-e-e-r-w-a-g-e-n
thank you
all right very good sir have a seat
please keep your voice up nice and loud
if you don't understand the question
from council please indicate that i'll
have them rephrase thank you go ahead mr
blancas good afternoon
good afternoon uh where do you currently
reside
i live in
washington township warren county
and what do you do for a living
uh
currently i am a life safety instructor
for surgery centers
i'm a retired firefighter
okay back in
august specifically august 6 2019 what
did you do i was the fire inspector for
washington township morris county
and can you give the ladies and
gentlemen and jury a little bit of your
background
working with washington township yes
or your previous employment that
allowed you to become
what you were there
i was
[Music]
a retired firefighter a fire captain
from maplewood new jersey i am also a
was a fire marshal for washington
township warren county
washington township mars county and
several other
towns independence in mansfield
and
back in
august of 2019
did you have an occasion to respond to
my client michael barrasson's uh farm
yes i did
and uh why did you respond it was at the
request of the at the fire marshal at
that
time
he asked me to take a ride with him to
issue uh violations
and and uh to your knowledge was a
complaint filed
at that time i wasn't aware of anything
no so basically you're just asked to
come along for the ride right correct
and
and uh prior to that day had you had
occasion to see michael barrasson before
no not at all
so on the sixth that was the first time
that you ever laid eyes on michael
barrisson correct that's correct
and and
can you describe his demeanor when you
first saw him
um when we arrived he approached us and
it was a
short dialogue and he was seemed very
upset to the point where he actually
started sobbing
actual sobbing
more than crying crying i use the word
sobbing as far as crime
did you ever determine
why he was crying or what issues he had
um
later on
uh
i'm going to object on speculation great
judgment
yeah
let me see that sidebar
you can rephrase if you wish to sure
mr herwagon um
with regards to these uh
code violations
uh did you when you were
his boss or colleague
determined
uh who was doing the construction
at the facility
um that was more on my boss's part okay
all right i have nothing funny thank you
any cross-examination of mr hugh wagon
briefly judge
uh mr herewagon do you know if the visit
to the property was announced to mr
barrisson before you went there
no i was not aware if it was or not i
know it was a second visit to the
property where my boss supervisor was
there earlier in the dead
where he uh i guess he viewed what was
supposed to have been
written up now he went back later that
afternoon to issue the construction
violations and when you talk about uh
that individual is that mr lopez that's
correct who else was at the property
when you were there from from the
township
uh neil giro he was the construction
official at the time
do you recall if uh ms cook gibbs was
there at that time no she was not i know
she wasn't there at the time it was just
the three of us
and you indicated that you had gone
there in your capacity uh as a
related to the fire inspection i was
asked to go along as a second party he
was issuing violations and you felt that
it was best to have somebody with him
and there were actual fire violations
located at the property
uh i believe so i did not see exactly
what they were
mr lopez would be more aware of what
exactly he wrote up i didn't write it up
no further questions judge
all right
can you redirect no all right you may
step down mr wagon thank you sir
call your next witness sir
matthew lopez
yes mr matthew lopez please
mr lopez please uh remain standing for a
minute left hand on the bible raise your
right hand please listen to my court
clerk do you certain the presence of
almighty god that the testimony gives to
this court regarding this matter shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth i will please state your
name as well your last name for the
record uh matthew lopez thank you
oh you may have a seat sir please keep
your voice up
that microphone only records it doesn't
project your voice in the courtroom so
keep your voice up so everyone can hear
if you don't understand the question
please indicate that i'll have counsel
rephrase very good mr malinkas go ahead
mr lopez
what do you do
i'm a fire inspector
and and for who for washington township
morris county and how long have you been
can you hear okay
sort of i see it's uh yeah leaning
forward a little bit try to keep and
there's a hand back there yeah i i
thought that just keep your voice up
nice and loud
go ahead
are we a fire inspector for washington
township correct
and how long you've been doing that
about 10 years
and what what training or experience you
have to to hold the position like that i
have a fire inspector fire official
certification to the state
okay
and you've been doing that for 10 years
at washington township washington
and
directing your attention to august 6th
did you respond to my client's uh
farm
in washington township i did
and
had you received a complaint
we did
i can approach i show you
d 100 e2
and ask you
if you recognize that document i do
recognize that
and is that the reason why uh you
decided to go out there on the
sixth that's correct
now prior to going out did you talk to
anybody about that
um
that complaint
we received the complaint and we decided
to go out to investigate the next day
okay and uh two people signed that
complaint correct
that's correct
and and prior to going out did you
attempt to contact
those people and
try to see what you were dealing with uh
we did not okay
so
does that complaint
accurately
depict
the reasons why you went out on that
particular day
yes stated fire code violations were at
the property okay
judge i move uh
d100 e2 into evidence
what's the basis for the objection
the same objection that i had with the
prior document i think this is your side
it's not an offer for the truth
is offered for the truth let me see it
come to cyborg please
all right rephrase your question mr
valencus
mr lopez uh in the complaint
to object to that judge
yeah just
it's your witness mr blinkist you can
ask him
what he did without getting into the
specifics
with regards to the
farmhouse
specifically the basement area
did you go and check
down there
to determine whether there were any
violations
yes we went down in the basement
and and what were you checking for
we were looking down in the basement we
were looking for fire code violations
uh
we were looking to see if anybody was
staying down there and if there was any
other violations such as
uh you know open wiring and missing fire
protection devices
and
were people staying down there
there was nobody there when we were
there
you checked the rest of the house
correct that's correct
and
based on your
inspection
did you wish you violations yes we did
what specifically did you issue
we issued a imminent hazard
for the house
and for the barn
okay let's let's talk about the house
first
what were the issues with the house
the house
had
zero smoked hard-wired smoke alarms
they were all missing from the ceiling
um
and then there was additional there was
open wiring throughout the building and
missing fire rated construction
from the first and second floor
i'm sorry what did you say about the
first and second floor i didn't catch
that it was missing firey to
construction
uh the ceiling was missing from the
first floor to the second floor
okay
and based on those
observations
did you issue a violation yes
and what's the
result of you issuing the violation what
are the consequences so to speak
um the owner operator of the property
would have to abate the violations
within the time frame that code allowed
and
is someone obligated to
move out
and
remain out of the residence until
those specific issues are addressed with
an imminent hazard
nobody has to go back into the property
unless it is to abate
the imminent hazard
i've seen pictures of
violations posted on the
back door did you post those i did
nobody was at the property at the house
when the
violations were issued so i posted
another building so anybody that came
back saw the violations were aware
all right now
would you
strike that what does the violation say
are the consequences to anyone
who ignores those violations and goes in
and resides in the residence
there's fines involved with that
up to five thousand dollars correct
and who's the owner of that property
based on your
investigation i had sweetgrass
farms
uh and barcelona um dressage as the
owner operator and that's michael
barrasson's company you know correct uh
yes
now
so i understand uh the sequence of
events
you place a violation on the the door of
the uh the farm house correct yes
and
there's another
stack of papers posted also what is that
uh i'm not sure why don't you show them
the photograph
if you have it
well when you make your determination
that there's a violation and
that people must leave what do you post
on the
uh the doors
i post the notice of violation after
i've issued it to the property owner
so at some point in time you go up to
the stable area correct
correct
and and uh
did you uh
post a similar type of violation
on that structure
i don't believe i did
i hand delivered it to
uh mr person
and when you say you hand delivered it
to whom my client
yes
and
was he basically based on your
your inspection
uh not allowed to
re-enter the property and sleep there
i no nobody can stay there until the
imminent hazard has been abated
can we clarify which property you're
speaking about i'm talking i thought i
did the stable area
i show you d800
81
and ask if if you know what those two
pieces of paper take to the back door
the one is my imminent hazard i'm not
sure what that other one is well who who
put that on the door
i know i i put the one on the left on
the door i don't recall what the one in
the middle is
i'm not sure what that one is in the
middle
well how many
packets do you normally put on a door
based on the violations that you
observed on that day i normally just
issue the imminent hazard and notice
violations
[Music]
i show you d500
and ask you if you recognize this stuff
yes that's the imminent hazard that's
posted on the left
okay and and basically what is what's
the purpose of this document
this document was posted the building
had an imaging hazard and anybody that
went to the building or tried to get
into the building knew that there was an
imminent hazard and was able to read it
and as you sit here today
i'm going to show you 872
which is the other document on the door
do you recognize that document
yes that's the letter for temporary
housing that the town had
uh asked the post
okay
judge i move
872
which is the
letter from the town posted on the door
that's already been introduced into
evidence and the
specific violation 500-5
as well as defense exhibit 881
which shows both documents
i think if it's the two pictures
and the actual violation that was posted
i don't have an objection
can i just confirm yeah just show mr
shellhorn what it is you're moving in
specifically
thank you
what are those numbers again mr malinkas
800-81
800-72
which is the letter
and the specific violation 500-5
but those matters will be admitted into
evidence no objection from the state and
i'd like to publish these to jerry
certainly
i'm putting on the
screening 881
are you going to turn the image please
judge your fighter
just quickly show the jury very quickly
sure
800-72 the letter
and finally
500-5 the
notice of eminent hazard
that was posted on the door
thank you
mr lopez
i'm not going to ask you the specifics
but did you have a conversation with
michael barrasson about
where he
and all the people who were residing in
the stable area were going to sleep
yes
and did you come back at any point and
see
mattresses laid out outside on the front
porch yes i did
and when did you see those mattresses on
the back porch um at the time that the
violation the imminent hazard had stated
now
did michael
barrasson
and all these staff members there com
complied with your order
to vacate the premises
they debated the violation by not
sleeping there and removing the
mattresses so yes
now
did you have any discussions with lauren
cataract
with regards to her staying in the
service
she emailed us
stating that she had received the
violations yes
so you got confirmation she was aware
then correct
correct
and i now
ask you what you said or what she said
but did you come to an arrangement
with lauren counteract
whereupon she was allowed to stay in the
farmhouse
she
and michael are robert goodwin abated
the imminent hazard
and therefore the imminent hazard was
abated
and
i could not there's no reason for me to
be able to keep them out
you basically gave them permission
based on what under the fire code under
the fire code to go back into that
residence correct because the imminent
hazard was abated
and to your knowledge did
she or robert goodwin take down
those violations that were posted with
the
uh
how would he know that
he didn't only know it if he returned to
the scene and we haven't established
that yet did you return to the scene at
any point when to check to see whether
those violations were abated
it was late at the night and they sent
me an emails with photos of everything
in working order theo of the smoke
alarms working
so
you did that based on what they told you
not what you saw or investigated correct
it was late at night and i was not going
to go out to the farm late at night they
sent us emails and videos of all the
devices working properly okay
now
when michael barissone was
violated from the stable area
did you advise him
of the violations concerning the
farmhouse because he was the owner i did
now after you allowed counteracting
goodwin
to go back into the residence did you at
any time notify michael barrisson the
owner
what you had done
not that night i didn't
we were going to do it in the morning
did you do it in the morning
i did not get to it in the morning no we
did not meant no so as far as michael
barrisson was concerned objection
yes mr blinkist not proper sustained
so before the shooting
did you notify michael barrasson
that cataract and goodwin
were allowed to remain in the residence
i did not have contact information for
michael from now
did you or anyone on your behalf
go out and remove those violation
notices
nobody from my office removed the
violation notices
and those are the violation notices that
i showed you in that picture correct
the ones that were on the door of the
house yes
sure
you have anything to do with the uh
stop construction orders
no that's that's ucc construction
i have nothing for you
cross-examination
thank you
so mr lopez uh
you were there on august 6th and issued
a number of fire violations at the house
correct and you also issued a number of
fire violations at the barn correct and
i think just to clear up what you were
just asked about
you got an email from ms canorack on
the night of august 6 2019 correct and
she actually sent you videos and
pictures that showed that there were
fire detector smoke detectors and things
of that nature yes
and from your perspective that abated
the hazard that you had observed the
imminent hazard at least for purposes of
that night correct
when you were at the property at some
point on august 6th
mr bulingus asked you about seeing
mattresses outside
the barn correct
and during the course of dealing with
michael barissone did he tell you that
he was going to be getting a hotel
correct
and you found that to be satisfactory
because
the barn is not a dwelling unit nobody
should be staying there
whose responsibility is it to fix uh or
remedy or abate an imminent hazard
the owner operator tenant occupant
and in this case you actually had ms
kanrak and mr goodwin abated what was
going on at the barn but nothing was
invaded at the
uh excuse me at the house but nothing
was evaded at the barn
no the barn was abated
the mattresses were removed so there was
no dwelling units inside the barn
anymore
i understood
nothing further on thank you
any redirect
right you may step down mr lopez thank
you
might call your next witness
mr dan
there you vitale
[Music]
hi mr
um left hand on the bible please raise
your right hand please listen to my
court clerk as she administers the oath
do you throw in the presence of almighty
god that the testimony goes to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth yes i do please state your
name as for your last name for the
record daniel vitale
v-i-t-a-l-e thank you all you may be
seated sir
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it does not
project your voice in the courtroom okay
all right so they have to hear your
voice if you don't understand the
question please indicate that i'll have
counsel rephrase okay all right go ahead
mr malinkas
mr vitale where do you currently live
uh i currently live in morris county
and what do you do for a living uh
currently i'm a firefighter paramedic
directing your attention uh back to
august
7th
2019
where were you working
st clare's hospital ems
and
what training
do you have
to become an ems
i went through emt school and then i
went through paramedic school
to become a paramedic where i was
working at the time
and how long were you working there uh
prior to uh august 7 2019
i would say it was a few years prior
maybe
three or four years prior to that date
so
again
your title is or was exactly what back
then
mobile intensive care paramedic
okay um on august 7th did you have an
occasion to uh come into contact with my
client michael barrison yes
and
how did that come about
we were called to
an address
um
and
we were dispatched there through our
dispatch center
and responded to that address where
he was located all right do you recall
what the address is as you sit here
today um i don't recall it's on my
patient care report okay i'm going to
show you d 600
and ask you to take a look at that and
see if that refreshes your recollection
as to where you went
and so am i crying michael barrasso
411 west mill road in long valley
and you're referring to to what an
official uh
document that was made uh yeah this this
is our patient care report
and what's included in this uh type of
report
um obviously all the dispatch dispatch
information times and our exam findings
uh were you there with someone else from
uh uh saint claire's ems services yes we
ride two paramedics in new jersey so my
partner kimberly held us with me all
right
and uh at some point in time did you uh
come into contact with michael barrison
yes
and uh
did you uh assess and treat him yes
in assessing him
uh
did you attempt to determine what
happened
we did it without you and and what was
he able to tell you about the incident
judge can we be heard at sidebar
yes
let me see that sidebar please
mr shanghai let me see you again please
thank you
in treating michael barrasson
did you ask him what happened
we did
and
what was his response
his response was that
someone was there to take his kids
and
he couldn't remember really much of
anything
did he give you any information as to
the actual event
now
now
did you make note of his uh
present mental status
we did
and and what was your observations of
barristone
while you were treating him
confused
did you receive information from anyone
else
at the scene
that you used as far as any uh treatment
that you did
i don't really understand the question
though okay let me try to rephrase it
i'm not sure i do either
um
did you see any injuries on michael
barrasson
we did yes
did you see get information from anyone
other than michael barrasson
as to what may have caused those
injuries
we did yes
and what was that the police department
how many will object to the
form of the question it's hearsay or
calls for a hearsay response that those
these are statements from others not
from
their statements with regards to
a specific injuries judge that he used
to determine what medical attention was
necessary
is that why did you ask others the
question
about what happened or did they
volunteer the information to you they
volunteered as we arrived on scene
and who specifically did you speak to do
you recall uh a patrolman i don't
remember his name it is reflected in my
uh patient care report he was the one
that transported with us and he gave you
information and
what was the reason did you need that
information
it's pretty typical when the paramedics
arrive on scene that the agency that's
currently there gives us an update as to
what's going on so we kind of know what
to do and who to approach who might need
our services who does not
all right so at that point in time when
you heard the statement you didn't
know who might need your services oh no
because we were just arriving on scene
right so
let me see you at sideboard please
uh just rephrase the question mr
belinkus in accordance with the court's
ruling please
mrs vitale did you received information
that michael barrisson had suffered dog
bites
at the scene yes
now
did you observe
various injuries to michael barrasson's
body yes
i'm going to show you a stack of
photographs
852 to
871
and could you just take a a quick look
at all of those
good while the witness is looking at
those perhaps we can come to cyborg
all right you know what why don't we do
this it's 10 after three we'll take our
afternoon recess we can talk about this
outside the jury's presence
and then we'll proceed all right i will
take 10 minutes ladies and gentlemen
you